hi guys Lauren good from wire here at
the Steve Jobs theater in Cupertino and
if you've been following the news and
you know that there are new iPhones or
just announced I have two of them here
with me unfortunately I only have two
hands so I couldn't fit the third but
there is one back there that I'm gonna
reference so this is the new iPhone 11
thankfully we are no longer calling at
the iPhone X or X s which was 410 this
is the iPhone 11 of pro max which means
this is the giant bonus in 6.5 inch
diagonal display back there there's the
iPhone 11 fro which is a more normal
sized phone but like I said I don't have
that one with me so let's talk about
these now I'm gonna talk about this one
first because I think this one is gonna
be pretty popular with people in many
ways this is successful to last year's
iPhones head of art which was considered
the cheaper iPhone and had a like liquid
crystal display it started at 750
dollars it came in this size phone it
had great battery life this is basically
the successor to that this iPhone 11
it's got a 6.1 inch diagonal display it
has the same apples calling it liquid
running up it's really a liquid crystal
displays an LCD it's not an OLED it's
probably gonna have a pretty good
battery life on the back here you'll
notice that there are now two camera
lenses last year's phone just had an
ultra wide camera lens if there's a
range of ultra wide photos that you can
take there still is no telephoto lens
but you're gonna get a better camera on
this and part of that is due to the a13
biotics sensor this is apple's new chip
every year they were they reveal a new
processor for their phones and this is
gonna have the latest and greatest chip
in it as well supposedly the glass has
been strengthened which is good because
last year as soon as I had the 10
10r i shattered it and the most
appealing thing about this is probably
gonna be at sir price point it starts at
$6.99 so it starts at even less than
last year's iPhone at NRA meanwhile the
10r is staying in the lineup and it's
going down to $5.99 so I think that's
gonna be appealing for a lot of people
this is the iPhone 10 whole excuse me
iPhone 11 Pro max or slot phones here
people I I also have my 10s with me from
last year seems a little wired pop
socket okay we're gonna put that one
aside though so this is like the top of
the line I phone that Apple just
announced and they're really targeting
this at pros creative professionals
people who shoot a lot of video who
capture a lot of photos of course they
even show the director you know using it
to shoot something that was really very
filming and cool looking whether you're
a pro or whether you're not a pro or
whether you're an aspiring pro if you
have eleven hundred dollars to spend
this is this is the phone for you this
does have the super Retina display it's
an OLED display it's really nice-looking
as you can see and on the back here
here's the big reveal three camera
sensors there's a telephoto there is
Melchor wide and there's a super ultra
wide and you might be wondering what all
that means well now when you open the
native camera app and you go to shoot a
photo you'll notice that you have
options here right you can zoom in
this or of course you can just use your
fingers to zoom in as well but it's a
way of giving you an ultra wide photo
option to capture even more detail in
frame there's also a new slow-mo selfie
feature apples trying to call this slow
fee I'm not even gonna try this right
now because I'm not quite sure how it
works yet portrait mode right now you
can they're like demos and shooting
portrait mode with your pets which is
great okay so the camera is better and
once again part of the reason why the
camera is better is because of this new
a 13 Bionic processor that Apple is
touting saying that its offloading some
of the processing processing of these
photos onto this chip specifically the
neural engine of the chip the idea is
now if you go to take a photo and maybe
it's not you know so light out and
you're capturing it in a dark
environment this camera app will
actually create a composite for you it
will capture us with up to nine images
at the same time and stitch it all
together this is not unlike what we've
seen folks like Google do right Google
doesn't necessarily have the best camera
hardware and its pixel phone so it's
using a lot of computational photography
software to stitch photos together and
make them look better and so that's
something that Apple is promising with
new camera it is computational
photography mad science supposed to have
better battery life in last year's model
still see a lightning pour it down here
so no USB see just yet and this one is
going to cost you it's gonna start at
1099 for the base model and it's gonna
go up from there and that one the iPhone
11 Pro which I don't have in hand is
going to start at 999 it's pretty much
aligned with last year's prices of the
iPhone 10s and 10's max my god there are
so many phones but yeah this is all part
of Apple's broader strategy of just
trying to sell more iPhones iPhone sales
have been slowing and so you know at the
high end there's a lot of competition
coming in from phone makers like Samsung
and Huawei and oneplus and you know on
the lower end it's not even low-end but
apples trying to appeal to maybe a more
cost sensitive customer as well by
offering phones while sure as low as
$5.99 let's see if it works
I don't know I'm gonna spend some time
with the phones this is not micro will
do so you're gonna have to check back
for information on wire calm